Now that we have an empty database,
let's populate it with some information.
With SQL, we would need to execute
an insert command with all of
the information we want it to
populate into our database.
Using SQLAlchemy,
creating a new database is as easy
as creating a new object in Python.
I will be executing these operations
from the Python show, but
they could also be done from
within a Python script.
We must first import the following
dependencies from SQLAlchemy, and
the empty database we created,
into our environment.
We will see what they
do in just a second.
From our database_setup.py
file that we created,
let's import our base restaurant,
and menu classes.
The create_engine function let's our
program know which database engine we
want to communicate with.
Then let's bind the engine to the base
class with the following command.
This command just makes the connections
between our class definitions and
the corresponding tables
within our database.
The next thing I'm going to do
is create a sessionmaker object.
This establishes a link of communication
between our code executions and
the engine we just created.
In order to create, read, update or
delete information on our database,
SQLAlchemy executes database
operations via an interface.
It's called a session.
A session allows us to write down all
the commands we want to execute, but
not send them to the database
until we call a commit.
Here, I'll show you what I mean.
I'm going to create an instance of a
DBSession and call it session for short.
From now on, when I want to
make a change to my database,
I can do it just by calling
a method from within session.
The DBSession object gives
me a staging zone for
all of the objects loaded into
a database session object.
Any change made to the objects in
the session won't be persisted into
the database until I
call session.commit.
Now as I promised,
making a new entry in our database is as
easy as making a new object in Python.
Take a look at these three
lines of example code and
watch as I implement them to create
a new restaurant in my database.
Following this example,
I'll make my first restaurant like so.
As you can see, it's just an instance
of my restaurant class with
a name attribute that I decided
to give it, Pizza Palace.
To persist my new restaurant
into the database,
I must do two more session operations.
First by calling session.add
my first restaurant,
my restaurant object is in the staging
zone to be added to the database.
Then with session.commit it's
now stored to my database.
But how do I know it worked?
Well, I can also use the session
to interact with my database and
see what's inside of it.
If I execute
session.query(Restaurant).all, I'm
asking my session to
go into the database,
find the table that corresponds
to the restaurant class and
find all the entires in that table and
return them in a list.
When I run this,
I get a response with something like,
database_setup.Restaurant object at and
some hexadecimal number.
This just let's us know that Python
found a restaurant in our database and
represents it as an object
at this location in memory.
I'm sure you're thinking, well that's
great but how's it useful to me?
We'll go into more detail about
the query method when we focus on
reading data out of our database.
So now, let's add a MenuItem
to our Pizza Palace menu.
Since our MenuItems all belong to
a Restaurant, and have a few more
attributes, we have to provide a bit
more information in our declaration.
I can create a Cheese Pizza by
executing the following command.
Notice that I provided all of the fields
of information for a MenuItem here and
specify the foreign key relationship
to the object name of my restaurant.
In order for this operation to work,
I didn't have to fill out every entry
unless I specified it as nullable equal
to false in our database_setup.py file.
Now let's run session.query
MenuItem .all to
see that an object now exists for
our cheese pizza item, as well.
Now that you know how to
add data to a database,
it's your turn to get
some practice at it.